[Music]
mathematics will fall first to being
solved by a i that is said franois flu
on December the 3D now on December the
13th Deep Mind published this paper in
nature having found new Solutions in
math and computer science with large
language models or short llms how did
large language models that are known to
hallucinate and give so many bogus
answers become such incredible math
solvers overnight that's what we'll
explain in this video so how can it be
that llms can make scientific
discoveries when they're known to
hallucinate and produce factually
incorrect information well let's
remember that they are also quite
creative at times and there is a
fundamental difference between everyday
natural language problems in mathematics
or code math and code have the great
property of
verifiability in other words once we
have a correct solution to a math or
coding problem we know where whether it
is correct as we see that the code
compiles and that the result is what we
expected so while llms produce piles of
garbage the pile comes with some nuggets
of creativity if there only was a way to
decide which Generations are garbage and
which ones are genius well there is this
new idea in the llm space of investing
compute at test time after the
generation suppose we have a problem
formulated as an llm prompt then we let
the model generate a million answers
then we let a verifier rate and rank
these million answers the verifier could
be a test we have written or even the
same model that generated the answers or
another capable model and yes you heard
correctly even the same model that
generated the answers would be quite
good at rating its own answers because
quality estimation is much easier than
generation think of it this way it is
much easier to say whether this solution
is correct or not then come up with it
yourself and since math and code
problems are very viable one can use
such verification tests to rank the top
Solutions and this is a recipe for how
to select genius answers from a wide
range of not so good model outputs the
key Insight behind the idea of test time
computation is that the model has been
training for months on internet scale
data and has achieved a certain amount
of capability so the capacity to perform
a task by transforming its inputs layer
by layer and arriving at the answer but
to increase the competency so the level
of skill on a task we could give it some
thinking time during inference by
letting it produce many answers like a
million and rank those and let it make
further computation with those in other
words we are replacing the reasoning we
were expecting from the model parameters
with Brute Force computation at
inference time now how did Deep Mind use
this idea in their nature paper to
develop fun search to solve
long-standing math and computer science
problems well because of what we said
previously about code verifiability you
maybe are not very surprised that for
solving math and computer science
problems they express them as code first
the mathematician describes the problem
in code and writes the tests that
evaluate the problem to tell apart
correct from wrong Solutions the
mathematician also writes an initial
program as a placeholder for the
solution by doing so they specify the
expected structure of the solution so
the whole thing is more like a skeleton
and it's useful to put prior knowledge
we have about the problem in there then
an llm iteratively improves the initial
program in principle the procedure could
use any llm working with code but the
Deep Mind authors use Codi which is a
code llm built on top of palm 2 so now
Codi improves this initial program by
generating many many programs like a
million not kidding it's a million and a
lot of them are garbage but some of them
are great the programs are automatically
evaluated on many inputs by the test
functions written by the mathematician
for each input programs get a score and
the final score of the program is an
aggregate over all inputs code that does
not compile uses more memory or time
then allowed or does not deliver valid
results was discarded but code that gets
high scores goes to a program database
then in the next iteration fun search
takes a program from the program
database as an initial program which is
now better than the last initialization
or rather they use a couple of these
best programs to fuse shot prompt the
model by showing it a couple of initial
programs sorted by quality with these
input programs they repeat the whole
process of generating a million
improvements ranking them based on how
well they perform on test inputs and put
the best programs into the program
database from which they sample the
initial program in the next iteration
again favoring higher scoring and
shorter programs okay this was the
method but did they solve actual
problems with this well the authors
wanted to solved the capset problem and
collaborated with Jordan Ellenberg a
mathematics professor at the University
of Wisconsin medicine known for making
an important breakthrough on the Caps
set problem the problem is about finding
the largest set of points called a cap
set on a high dimensional grid where no
three points are on a line what seems to
be a weird graph Theory problem is a
model for other problems in extremal
combinatorics asking how large or small
a set of objects can be famous
mathematician teren too described this
as his favorite open question the
problem is extremely hard to Brute Force
because the number of possibilities to
consider becomes extremely large super
fast larger than the numbers of atoms in
the universe which are 10 to the power
of 82 and trust me I've counted now fun
search Solutions were programs that
discovered the largest cap sets for some
settings that were never found before
the authors say that this is the largest
increase in the size of capets in the
past 20 years and the authors did not
stop at the capset problem and went onto
the bin packing problem in computer
science here the problem is to determine
how to pack items of different sizes
into the smallest number of bins this
has numerous applications in real life
think of how to pack your suitcases when
flying overseas loading containers into
ships or loading data into your computer
memory or allocating jobs on a cluster
usually this problem is solved by
juristic devised by humans but it is
hard to find good juristic for each
specific situation fun search
automatically gave specific programs
adapted to the specifics of the data and
situation ations outperforming human
euristic now fun search helping make
these breakthroughs is huge news if you
ask me I was super impressed and yes
maybe mathematics is a domain where AI
can be already put to use especially
since verifiability is easier than with
other domains fun search has shown that
one can usefully leverage imperfect and
hallucinatory llms as long as one has
the compute to produce a million of
temperation and verify them Jordan
Ellenberg the mathematician
collaborating with deep mind on the Caps
set problem said that the solutions
generated by fund search are far
conceptually richer than a mere list of
numbers when I study them I learn
something which might mean AI will
become a tool for mathematicians to Aid
their discoveries in the near future
here's what the fields medalist Yugo Dil
copon said after I asked him about AI in
mathematics at the last heidleberg
laured Forum in September
2023 question how we will be creative I
mean how the this these computers are
going to be creative in terms of of of
mathematics beyond the question of
whether you can uh understand Concepts
which is still something that I think is
a big challenge in for AI so creativity
it's a good question whether it's going
to be able to replace Us by being
creative in particular how you would
Implement maybe the weaknesses of the
mathematician that make it a creative
person I'm bad at Computing and this is
a very good skill right because that
actually forces me to go around and try
to find shortcuts so uh on this point I
don't know if it it's soon that we are
going to be replaced now in terms of
helping which is already something good
like to be a enhanced mathematician in
some sense uh it's a very good question
so far it's not so helpful like I If you
take chat GPT or things like that it's
completely useless for us except for
writing recommendation letters
apparently but I still don't use it but
um if you are honest as a mathematician
a lot a big part of your creativity is
emergent creativity it's like you learn
things and out of learning those things
just something emerges and and so so we
are not so good at learning where AI is
very good so if we can find uh once AI
will be able to recognize concept and uh
speak about Concept in a more uh
efficient way it may be that it's going
to become a very useful tool for you
know this LMA that's still going to take
me two months to prove even though it's
not the core of my uh my paper my
argument but well this LMA quite often
you know you you you work for two months
you prove it you put the thing on the
archive and then some guy or some girl
from the other side of the world tells
you oh it's funny I Pro this LMA in my
paper from 1982 and you're like oh man
if I would have known that was two
months uh that we would gain this I
think there's going to be a big uh a big
progress with AI
probably it will be very helpful for
this kind of speeding up the process
checking proof which is the last thing
that people think of in terms of
usefulness of of AI like of computers
can they check proof instead of us it's
a very interesting thing but the cost
that uh that it takes to actually
transform the proof into something
checkable is for now so big that it's
definitely faster to ask people to check
the proof in the first place now what do
you think of fun search are you worried
of AI taking over mathematicians jobs
should you now switch fields and give up
mathematics well it is on you to decide
but I would rather say that an
interesting time is coming for
mathematics and it might get very busy
and vibrant there it's not like AI will
will solve math by itself because these
AIS are not independent remember fun
search needed the input of the
mathematician and the problem
description and test to be able to work
but thanks to AI you could make use of
some programming skills and solve
problems that you were not able to crack
before thanks for watching this far if
you want to see more videos like this
one subscribe to the channel and see you
next time okay
bye
[Music]
he